What's going on, Gavin?
Eritrea for a trip
and this is...
Well it's been
quite a journey already actually.
Went to the Berlin embassy.
I went once, you went what, three times?
I went four times.
Four times and you got it
last minute, the last day.
Literally last minute
after they told me I wasn't gonna get it.
I was gonna do all sorts of shenanigans.
I was gonna try to
get on this flight without a visa.
WOMAN: Asmara.
PETER: Asmara?
PETER: Okay.
And this lady's been like a mother to me.
She's amazing.
She gave me her bread at the airport
and she's been very kind and gentle
and given me nice smiles
and tried to give me more tea.
And just all around,
a very cool, warm person.
To be continued.
Everyone has been super-rad so far.
So many people just
come straight up to us.
-Talk to us, tell us a story.
-Super friendly.
They're pumped that
we're visiting their country.
Not as pumped as we are!
♪ warm electronic ♪
[music intensifies]
[crowd cheering]
[bicycles passing]
♪ upbeat modern African ♪
[woman laughing]
<GAVIN: Say it again.
PETER: This guy said he's very strong.
PETER: Let's see how strong he is.
[bystanders laughing]
[encouraging chatter]
GAVIN: You got this, c'mon man!
PETER: Up, up, up, up...
GAVIN: Oh yeah.
[crowd cheering and laughing]
So in Eritrea when you
want to change money
don't do it in the bank
because it's 15 to 1, the exchange rate
and on the so called...
Whatever market you wanna call it
it's 24 to 1.
So it's the process of
getting bags of money
and doing a lot of counting
GAVIN: With the mafia.
I'm on the outskirts of Asmara
and I've found quite an interesting place.
Basically it is the resting point for all
of these tanks, and trucks,
and military hardware from...
I'm thinking from
the 30 year war here with Ethiopia.
But it goes on, and on, and on.
And...
It's an awesome site because
I've never seen anything like it.
It's also very depressing and...
Gross site of what humans...
Spend money on and do to each other.
Day two...
Quite a really, really, fascinating find.
This city and this country.
♪ upbeat modern African ♪
[music fades into choir singing]
This is a little bit different
to anywhere I've been
let alone Berlin.
It's obvious from this beautiful picture
that we're not in Berlin.
-Where are we, Gav?
-We're in Eritrea.
We're about an hour from the capital
in this place called Dekemhare.
It's one of the most
chill places I've ever been.
GAVIN: Woo.
[children cheering]
GAVIN: F*ckin' A, that was great.
[children giggling]
[children cheering]
Everyone's excited.
[all cheering and laughing]
[children cheering]
PETER: One, two, three, go!
[children yelling and cheering]
[coffee shop chatter]
[espresso machine hissing]
Feeling quite ill
but we're super lucky to get on this bus.
It's the only one going to a city
and we got it before it got the bus stop.
[grunting]
It's more than a handshake,
it's a shoulder bumper.
Brother...
One more time.
[grunting]
GAVIN: Zopo!
[Gavin chuckling]
In the city of Massawa, the old city here
and it's...
It's beautiful but it's sort of in ruins.
Old Ottoman architecture.
And...
Most other countries,
this would be a big tourist draw
but in Eritrea...
Well...
Not so much...
Because...
Well, there are hardly any tourists here.
There's like...
I think we've seen
in 10 days maybe like...
six white people.
Something like that.
Really, really an
off the beaten path type place.
So check this out, this is cool.
♪ African pop music in the background ♪
And people are just living in this.
In this old city.
And it's...
I think it got hammered
pretty hard in the war.
That's why it's all beat up but...
Yeah, really, really interesting place.
And the situation is
we're about to go into Sweets.
We've been thinking about Sweets for days,
even you, Gavin Hamilton.
Who doesn't have
a massive sweet tooth like me
has been talking
about this place for days.
Why? They have amazing desserts.
[Peter talking to staff inaudibly]
[Gavin chuckling]
[claps]
Yes.
Talk to the people.
Talk to the people, Mare.
Nice to meet you, Peter.
And your friends, hi to everybody.
Come Eritrea.
Why should they come to Asmara?
Because it is
very beautiful city like London.
[Peter chuckles]
It's like London but different.
But I'll say the people are nicer.
-Yeah.
-People are friendlier, like Mare.
Everybody's gentle and we are fun.
They give you peace.
[hands slap]
[both laughing]
♪ upbeat tropical African ♪